[Music]
hello everyone welcome to GCP next 2018
I'm really glad that all of you could
make it
my name is Neha Putin and I'm a software
engineer at Google
I work as TL on B PC I'm going to be
joined by Emmanuel and Kamal today and
we are going to do a deep dive into
Google V PC so to start off with what is
a V PC a VB C stands for virtual private
cloud a concept that I'm sure most of
you are familiar with a virtual private
cloud is a logical isolation of a
section of your cloud and it is a cloud
equivalent of your traditional network
that you would run in your own data
center but with the extremely important
added benefits of running on
infrastructure that is highly optimized
for scale performance and reduced
network costs we have a 50 minute talk
today I'm going to be introducing a few
core VPC concepts and walking you
through some of the work that we've been
doing over the past one year and also
mentioning some best practices that we
recommend Emanuel who is a networking
product specialist at Google will be
walking us through a few example be PC
topologies and kamal who is our guest
from paypal will be walking us through
PayPal's experience of using Google V PC
now what is the first thing that you do
when you want to check whether your
internet connectivity is working
correctly or not if you're a networking
expert the answer may be slightly
different but for most of the world the
answer is to open a web browser navigate
to google.com and check whether that web
page loads correctly or not using google
cloud gives you the unique opportunity
of using the same underlying network
infrastructure that powers all of Google
services like search maps YouTube Gmail
and VPC is a really simple and intuitive
interface to this infrastructure and it
provides to you programmable distributed
networking functions so what's unique
about Google V PC
most importantly it uses the highly
optimized low congestion and high
bandwidth high quality of service global
network backbone now this is important
for many reasons
it allows you the capability of creating
virtual machines anywhere in the world
in many regions and having private
connectivity between all of these
virtual machines by default so you don't
need to setup expensive VPN connections
or peering connections you don't need to
give your virtual machines public IPS in
order for these virtual machines to be
able to communicate with each other
across regions it allows you to appear
with GCP at a single location and to get
access to all of your workloads running
globally using Google cloud load
balancer you can create a global load
balancing application and you can rest
assured that the load balancer will send
requests to your to the closest backends
that are healthy and that are closest to
the end users that is sending the
request now this is really important
because it improves the perception of
performance of your application using a
single global VP C that is shareable in
nature allows you to administer your
network centrally while allowing
thousands of developers and development
teams in your organization to create
their own projects to create and manage
their compute resources in through
private access you can enable virtual
machines in your V PC to have access to
Google ap is like your GCS buckets
without having to assign public IPS to
these VMs so the traffic that goes from
the virtual machines to your storage API
for example would use the network
backbone and would not use the internet
but all of these things sound very 2017
right what is new about VP sees in 2018
we've been working really hard over the
past year to build the model of VP C's
to be more secure scalable performant
and easy to use all the data traffic in
GCP gets authenticated and encrypted
when it exits the physical boundary that
is owned by Google or operated on behalf
of Google we use the same DDoS
protection system in the cloud as we do
for the rest of Google so you get the
benefit of parameter security
we built and announced a product around
us called floud armor which allows you
fine-grained control over the rules that
you can specify for the parameter
security and these rules can be IP
blacklist white lists or vassals or you
can specify geo specific rules for
allowing traffic into your load-balanced
applications we provide Network layer
security through stateful connection
tracked firewall rules that are
implemented in a distributed fashion and
so are very scalable the u.s. Andromeda
which is the Sdn virtualization stack
and we have made several improvements in
the Andromeda control cleaner
infrastructure over the past year which
have enabled us to more than double the
number of virtual machines that you can
create in a single V PC we take
performance very seriously we launched
Andromeda 2.1 late last year which gave
a 40% reduction in the cross VM Layton
sees within a single zone over Andromeda
2.0 and it does this through an
optimization by bypassing the hypervisor
threads for network traffic that is
going from the virtual machine to the
software switch on the host machine
we also made several changes that enable
fine-grained ion access control and
integration with third-party services
using V PC peering now one of the more
exciting initiatives we have had within
the V PC team is to take a kubernetes
first approach and so we have made
several changes in V PC inherently in
order to better support kubernetes as a
first-class citizen through GK now
whether you're cloud native or you are
also running your workloads in your
on-prem datacenter or you may be running
workloads in another cloud as well you
may start small in a single region or as
or in a small set of regions but
your application grows and as you need
to expand globally you may expand to
multiple regions but the configuration
that you did initially just seamlessly
works and so the overhead of network
administration and management doesn't
grow with the number of regions that you
need to put your computer resources in
now let's walk through the different
aspects of VPC the first aspect that I'm
going to be talking about is that of a
network now a network maps to a global
virtual network that you can create
virtual machines in and it basically
consists of regional sub networks that
have non overlapping IP ranges now
before I explain the concept of a shared
VPC I'm going to step back a bit and
talk to you about a project now project
is a granular unit in GCP which is a
container that you can put resources
inside so if you want to create
resources like firewall rules routing
policies a network or virtual machines
or VPN connections you can create them
inside of a rese inside of a project a
project is also a basic unit that you
can attach billing accounts to that you
can specify I am policies on and that
you can manage quota on so it gives you
a container that you can completely
manage and then you can have full
control over the lifecycle management of
your resources
now it's shared VPC you get the ability
to create a vbc centrally in your
organization in a project called the
host project and to share that with
thousands of other projects in your
organization called service projects
that you that you can create virtual
machines in and have these virtual
machines be connected to the shared VPC
now this is really important because it
allows you to scale your organization to
thousands of developers or development
teams while centrally managing the
firewall rules the routing policy is the
VPN connections and not having to create
these every time a new project has gone
up
so what's new in this space
now with shared BBC you can administer
the shared VPC in folders and so for
example if you
want to isolate your billing pipeline
VPC from your web app VPC then you can
do so by having separate folders for
these two projects and having separate
share BBC administrators who can set up
the respective share be pcs one of the
things that we recommend doing here is
to put all the service projects for a
given share BBC set up inside the same
folder so that you can associate org
level policies on that folder at a later
time another thing that we recommend
doing is to use sub Network level
permissions so that you can specify
which service projects have access to
create virtual machines in which
specific sub networks that gives you
fine-grained access control another
feature that we have launched to GA over
the past year is the ability to create
private IP reservation and so you can
reserve RFC 1918 IP addresses and you
can use these for creating virtual
machines or internal load balancers in
your service projects another feature
that we have launched to GA over the
past year is alias IP ranges now alias
IP ranges give you the ability to create
alias or secondary IPs and associate
these with network interfaces of your
virtual machines you can allocate alias
IPS through primary or secondary ranges
on your sub network now if you use gke
to manage workloads running in
containers on your GC VMs then alias IP
ranges gives you the ability to
centrally manage all of your RFC 1918 IP
addresses so your pod IP is your node
IPS cluster IPS are allocated from the
primary and secondary ranges of your sub
networks it also gives native support
for routing and so it scales better and
you can create more nodes in the cluster
if you use TK to create an increase load
balancer with a network endpoint group
then you can rest assured that the front
end of the load balancer would load
balance directly to the pods that are
back ends of the load balancer rather
than having the front end of the load
balancer load balanced to virtual
machines which then have IP table
to route the packet to the back in
points so using Network endpoint groups
we get rid of this this extra hop in the
request path and so it is basically
optimizing the load balancing
application performance
it also gives native support for health
checking and so we are able to health
check the pods directly rather than
health check the virtual machines so as
I mentioned before alias IPS can be
allocated from primary or secondary
ranges in a sub network if you're
running out of IP space you can add more
secondary ranges on the sub network or
you can expand the existing primary or
secondary ranges now one of the things
that we recommend doing when you are
planning your IP space is to plan it in
such a way that you leave enough room
for growth now if you're running an
application on your VM and you're using
an alias IP to run the application then
you may want to move the IP from one VM
to another if the part that you're
running the application and dies or the
application crashes and you can do this
by deleting the alias IP on VM 1 adding
it to VM 2 creating a part there and
starting your application in vm 2 so
this is basically how you migrate an IP
from one VM to another VM now the next
aspect I'll be talking about a security
as I mentioned before we provide network
layer firewall rules but the way we
implement these firewall rules is not
through a middle box or a proxy and so
there are no single choke points
firewall rules are programmed on every
single host machine that has virtual
machines running in your V PC and so
they are truly distributed in nature the
rules themselves are flexible in
allowing ingress egress allow or deny
rules using priorities you can use tags
to easily group the virtual machines
that you want to apply specific firewall
policies on now when a developer adds a
tag to the a virtual machine there is no
echo check that happens by default
this is because if you own a virtual
machine if you have access to said tanks
on it then you are able to associate any
tag with the virtual machine now if the
service provided by your organization is
security sensitive internally or
externally then this may be problematic
and we solve this problem using
firewalls with service accounts so we
are happy to announce that this is now
available in GA you can associate a
service account and you can create that
as a source or a target of a firewall
and you can rest assured that when a
developer Associates a service account
with their VM then there is an echo
check that happens they need to have
I am permission on using that service
account now you configured your VPC
topology you carved out the IP space you
created the sub networks in different
regions and you created the firewall
rules to ensure that the traffic within
the VPC is secure now the next thing you
would like to do is connect your V PC
running in the cloud with your on-prem
datacenter now there are multiple ways
of doing this if bandwidth is not of a
major concern for you if you are okay
with the overhead of IPSec encryption it
basically uses the Internet then you can
use VPN and there are two ways of using
VPN connections as well you can either
create started Crouse to your VPN tunnel
which basically allow you to statically
specify the prefixes that should be
routed to your own pen or you can use
cloud router which runs as a bgp daemon
to exchange routes with your own frame
dynamically now one thing worth
mentioning about cloud router is that
you know unlike what the name might
suggest it's not a traditional router
and so packets that are going to your
own frame or coming from your own frame
to the VPC are not going through the
cloud router cloud router is a control
plane component and it basically is
responsible for programming the routes
that it learns from the on plan onto the
host machines that have virtual machines
in your V PC running on those host
machines host machines now if
but is of a major concern for you then
you can use interconnects if your if you
would like to directly pur with Google
if you have a public ESN and you want to
basically connect with us at one of our
pops or points of presence then you can
use dedicated interconnect if you're
doing the same thing using carriers
infrastructure and you're paying the
carrier for the service then you would
use partner interconnect we are really
excited that both dedicated and partner
interconnect are now generally available
there's a talk at 11:40 on hybrid
connectivity that I would highly
recommend checking out now a couple of
features that I would like to talk about
that are new in the dynamic routing
space our global BGP routing in custom
right route advertisements using global
BGP routing you can announce prefixes
that belong to sub networks in other
regions using a cloud router in one
region and we recommend doing this for
enabling redundancy in your connection
to your on-prem and so you can have
flower routers in two regions to your
global VPC and you can enable global BGP
routing on your V PC and this would
enable you to have local routes as well
as remote routes through the other
region now cloud router will add weight
to the remote routes so it would always
prefer the local routes but if your
local connection if your local VPN
connection or interconnect goes down
then the remote route would be used and
so you can fall back to using the routes
in different region so this gives you
higher availability you can use custom
route advertisements to choose prefixes
that you want to announce to your conne
trend and so you can choose tree fixes
that you don't want to announce you can
use custom route advertisements also to
announce prefixes that don't belong to
sub networks in your V PC and these may
be RFC 1918 IP or IP ranges or non RFC
1918 as well
now the next thing I'm going to talk
about is using third-party services now
shared way PC was designed with the
intention of having private connectivity
between virtual worship but between
virtual machines in one organization but
if you want to connect to VP sees in two
different organizations the typical
consumer and producer scenario then you
can use V PC peering V PC peering is
also not implemented through a proxy and
it is truly distributed in nature and so
there is no single point of failure with
vbc peering either when you appear to V
pcs you get full connection and you get
full connectivity to all the virtual
machines in the pure V PC and you also
get access to all the services that the
pure V PC is exposing through internal
load balancers now one of the things
that I want to mention about both share
V PC as well as V PC PR ink is that in
both cases you get high throughput and
bandwidth and you get the same
throughput in bandwidth as though if you
were to create those two virtual
machines in the same network in the same
project and this is because that aspect
of network topology is pretty much
transparent to the Sdn data plane if
you're a service provider and you would
like to have a management interface to
the virtual machines that are serving
traffic to your consumer then you can do
so by creating a virtual machine with
multiple network interfaces you can
create up to eight network interfaces on
your virtual machine and the traffic
basically on those two network
interfaces will be completely isolated
so your data plane network will be fully
isolated from your management network
now the last aspect I'll be talking
about is that of monitoring as you know
GCE is integrated with star driver and
so if you use features like global load
balancing or internal load balancer then
you'll be able to view the logs for
these features in stackdriver
we're really excited to now announce the
general availability of V PC flow logs V
PC flows also allow you
to view the VPC flows which are
aggregated over five seconds by
connection and you can enable this
feature on a per sub Network pieces on
the console you can choose the log type
as VP C flows and you can then view the
connections that are logged each log
will show you the five couple of the
connection along with other meta
information like source test BBC source
test subnetwork and other annotation
information like geo annotations that we
add on top of that on the logs you can
export this to bigquery or pub/sub and
you can use this feature for network
forensics for troubleshooting your
network as well as for analyzing the
different traffic patterns in your
network across geographies and to use
that information to better improve the
topology of your network to reduce costs
now you may have started small in a
single or a small set of regions but the
configuration that you did initially by
creating the network by creating the
firewall rules by setting up VPC peering
these things just seamlessly work as you
grow to more regions with the VPC design
we make sure that the cost and overhead
of network administration and management
doesn't grow linearly with the scale of
your network footprint we really think
of this model of VP C's as being the
true next generation of how P PCs are
defined in the cloud and we're really
excited to see how you use them we've
been working closely with some of the
top names in education banking software
technology mobile apps you know you name
it and they've been giving us some
excellent feedback on how to improve our
features you know it's really been a fun
ride so far now three things that I want
you to take away from this presentation
are that globe are that VP C's are
global in nature they use the same
underlying network infrastructure as the
rest of Google that allows you to do
amazing things at scale they're highly
performant we take performance where
seriously as I mentioned earlier we've
been making a lot of progress in
improving performance of our network but
we're also looking for new ways of doing
this we have a lot of ongoing investment
and so you can expect to see more
performance improvements in the coming
future and lastly that VP sees are easy
to use as you can imagine the network is
very powerful but also very complex and
B pcs provide a simple and intuitive
interface to this complex infrastructure
that allows you extensibility access
control and integration with third-party
services and with that I would like to
invite a manual on stage to share a few
example vbc topologies thanks now so
we're gonna run some through example
topologies that uses all the concept and
that they are just explained before
going over that I just want to quickly
recap a couple of things so if you look
at from the routing point of view VPC is
really a routing to me that's what you
get when you create a V PC it does
provide you internal IP connectivity
across all your sub networks that's a
matter in which region they exist and
without actually the traffic leaving the
Google Network so they all the traffic
stays inside Google Network may I
mention that we have a project concept
so the project is a unit of building is
a unit of permissions as a unit of
resources and yes you can have multiple
V pcs in the same project if you do that
you get two completely disjoint routing
domains which means like in the example
here you can have 2 V pcs with
overlapping IP subnets so in this
picture and you can see that DP C 1 and
V PC 2 as overlapping in uswest
- of course this is possible because
they're disjoint they do not speak
across themselves by design unless you
want it to and then the cloud router so
as I was saying it's a BGP speaker
process think about it like a route
processor in
physical router word it does not do data
plain the wall goal in life of this guy
is to get routes from outside and
program them into the DPC and gets route
from the V PC and send them outside as
you can see in the picture it can
programs route across all regions so in
this example the Colorado exists in u.s.
West one but it's able also to advertise
sub network that exists in u.s. West too
which is the tenth one 240 1/24 and he
also able to advertise sub matters that
do not exist in your EBC this example
the 10 239 2/24 okay now now that these
two concepts are clear let's start
looking at some potential topologies so
in this one we're using V PC peering in
producer-consumer scenario so we have on
top a provider project in the blue org
and at the bottom we got to consumer
projects one in the green org and one in
the red org so please note that these
three projects are in three different
organizations and now what the provider
projects want to provide is common
services that must be used from both
consumer project in the green org and
consumer project in the right org so the
way I can do this
I do this through V PC peering so I do
the PC peering from from the green or V
PC to the leftmost V piece in the
provider project and the red one is
peering with the rightmost one note that
here I got full overlapping IP across
the consumer project both consumer
project using the same sub networks
that's why I need two different V pcs in
the provider project tenant isolation in
the provider project is done by default
because those two V pieces are separated
route in domains so there is no
connectivity possible you don't need to
use photo routes for that share V PC so
I'm going to show you a simple example
our share V PC can be used with a
multiple tier application and the goal
of these topology is to base
Italy centralized networking and
security configurations and operations
in the ostridge and by using sherry PC
and giving different giving different
users different permissions to use
different subnets and we'll see that and
then I be able to have each team each
team of the team of the front-end
service project and of the can service
project manage their they earn compute
by themselves and this is of course
fully compatible with load balancers and
floor locks so how does that work so
basically first India's project I create
a sub Network
an orange sub Network and it's connected
to the shell V PC rather and I give
permission to the orange user to use the
sub network subnet or is an object so
you can give permission to this object
now what happens is this orange user
that exists in the service project logs
into the service project create
instances and when Andy sees dead sub
Network as available to connect
instances on to even if that sub Network
does exist India's project from Iran
from the networking point of view those
two instances is just like if they are
connected to the O's project from the
compute point of view they exist in the
service project so building for the
instances is on the service project now
from there the orange user create a
global load balancer protecting the
front end with cloud armor for example
and started track traffic from the
internet now I'm also creating another
sub Network in this project and this
time I'm giving it permission to use
this sudden effort to the blue user the
blue user is a user that exists in the
backend service project so what this
user does is logs into his service
project and create an ILB create
instances and as the orange user
previously he sees the sub Network
India's project as available to connect
his instances to and available to create
the VIP of an internal load balancer and
from here I got full IP connectivity
between front-end and back-end exactly
like those two tier two set of instances
are connect
to the same VPC on the O's project same
idea but on a different concept so I
want to use a network virtual appliance
to provide security and networking
services to multiple projects at the
same time so what I can do is create a
network virtual appliance which is a
multi NIC appliance and the snare was
saying multi NIC instance appliance in
this case in your multi nice unique
instance each interface needs to be
connected to a different V PC so here in
this example I got those two st. to Stu
V pcs that say they are two internal V
pcs okay and I'm using the same concept
of shared V PC so I'm sharing something
with the orange user into blue users and
they create your instances and internal
balance are exactly like before and then
the natural it or appliance also has a
northbound I should say eastbound in
this picture external interface it is
connected to the external V PC so the
one on the right that does bgp with the
Colorado with your on-prem so in this
example all the instances be m1 v m2 in
v n3 v n4 do get connectivity with on
pram and deleverage network again
security services provided centrally by
the network all appliance in your
project the next one is a more complex
one I would say but not that much she
shall be PC with shared interconnect so
what's the goal the goal is that I want
to leverage the same dedicating
interconnect across multiple projects
why because the dicket interconnect is a
precious resource it provides I
bandwidth connectivity and it has a cost
so I want to use it as much as possible
and I want to keep the operational and
management advantages of the share V PC
model I shown before and also I want to
allocate cost across projects in a
meaningful way
so how can we meet these goals so first
so we create one project where the
dedicate interconnect exists is created
and then you have one or more shell VPC
or project each one with its own cloud
router and each one with its own
interconnect attachment as we will see
those interconnect attachment will use
that it is interconnect that leaves in a
different project because again
everything in GCP it's it's an object so
also the delicate interconnect is an
object and as permissions how you do
security the best practice near a
command it was to you is to use fire
rules based on service account and VPC
for logs will give you complete
visibility of traffic including the
service service VPC and yaws to the pc
so visually how that looks like so if
you look here first so here so this is
the physical world so this is a color
sight and you have your your router here
and this is our peering fabric device so
this this site will be provided to get
interconnect and this di is the Dedic
interconnect physically support channel
so that's where the connection is built
now if you forget about the physical and
think about the cloud as an object model
the dedicated interconnect is an object
that lives in a project so you go into a
project and you say I want to dedicate
interconnect now we got in this example
to share VPC okay
the structure is the same as the one
that I was basically showing you before
and what is to be noticed here that each
of those to share with PC dos project as
a villain attachment and a cloud router
so know that the villain attachment is
is an object that lives in the O's
project but it is using dedicate
interconnected lives in dedicate
interconnect project so you can have a
single project with the data gate
interconnect and you can use it to
basically share the bandwidth across
multiple in this case those projects of
a share V PC configuration of course you
can have if you want you can have full
overlapping IP support because from our
side I mean the tenancy is provided by
the fact that we have two different V
pcs and on your side and customer side
of course you have to terminate is if
there is overlapping EUR to terminate
them in two different we arrive for
example and then bring the tenancy
inside your network to MPLS VPN or
whatever you you used to so we basically
met all these goals and a couple of
consideration so about the building so
the dicket interconnect gets built
against that project the project where
it exists the villain attachment it gets
build again the u.s. project degress
traffic from the instances gets built in
but on the service project were the
distances lives not on those project so
if you have multiple teams different
team does manage the service project
they you can do cost you can know how
much traffic and egress course they are
basically using there's a common in a
space spanning each shell V PC domain is
a native capability of shell V PC and V
PC for logs about saying contains
information bought about the service
project and your project so if you look
at the for logs you will see in the
source instance and destination instance
field you will see the service project
where the instance he actually lives and
if you look in the service if source
repition destination V PC you will see
the OS project where the instance is to
which the instances are attached
so if two more one is a classical I
throughput VPN connection so in this
example you have two VPN gateways in
your V PC in this example they are in
two different regions and you have
multiple VPN tunnels for each VPN
gateway we can do since we can do we
call cost multi-part per flow of course
from GCP to M Prime
this basically gives you a high
throughput connectivity between your
on-prem sorry your dishes we product and
project and neon pram there are multiple
ways you can do you can set up this the
suggestion is for sure do route based to
start with because it's more flexible
but the thing I always suggest to
customer is to start if possible with
the cloud router and BGP why because the
moment you switch they get interconnect
the routing will be exactly the same so
you can test and get confident of your
routing set up with VPN and then move to
they get interconnect and you don't
change a thing you can actually use VPN
as a backup of the decay to interconnect
and this is what I'm showing you in the
last slide so the what I'm leveraging
here is the global routing feature of
the table router so I basically send
let's say that I want to give reach
ability to ESC subnets I sent two
advertisement from the US east cloud
rather on the green on the green region
and we'd met 120 so Matt is a BGP
attributes basically that you can set on
the cloud router in this way and then
thanks to global routing also the router
in u.s. West knows about the US East one
subnet but we automatically add an inter
region cost to that route which is that
201 which means that when cloud router
adverted the cloud router in the orange
region advertised sub networks they
automatically get
an additional math and higher med than
120 meaning 120 plus 200 0 1 and that
200 ero 1 is just an example it's
dynamically calculated by the platform
in this way you're sure that both r1 and
r2 use the interconnect default and when
those interconnects are down you use a
VPN as a backup the same thing you can
do on the reverse side and on the
reverse side is actually easier because
even if you advertise the same Matt from
on prime to your cloud routers we
automatically add that inter region cost
when we program when the orange the
cloud routers that lives in the orange
region program the routes on the V PC we
have traumatically do that because the
subnets are living in a different region
in the green one so that gives you
automatic load balancing and usage of
the dedicated interconnect as a primary
and only the VPN only as a backup and
with that will to come out it will tell
you how there you outweigh part is using
V PC in their production network thank
you
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone my name is Komal
I'm part of the core platform and
infrastructure team at PayPal so at
PayPal we started our public cloud
journey a couple of years back so when
we started looking at how people can
expand into public cloud and we are
having one of the largest private data
centers so we started looking at what is
needed and what we need to do to get
into public cloud we soon realized that
two important things one is that it is
not a one-year or a two-year journey
just like that we can just jump into a
public cloud it is a multi your journey
because it involved culture change
mindset change tools are change and even
some application rewrites as we move
into that the second thing we realized
was none of the public cloud had all the
features for supporting enterprises to
run in a more secure and scalable way so
it means that we need a partner to
journey with us and we travel along with
them in this multi your journey to get
to the state where we can run a big
enterprise on public log so with that
one of the key things we started looking
at is that how do you build building
blocks in the public cloud so that we
can start figuring out how to move
things in a phased manner because we
cannot move everything so one of the key
pieces which we started looking at is
how do you build this VPC in public law
so with that I'll go to one of the use
cases which we started with and how we
went through the process of moving into
public law
so the first use case we took was a dev
use case which is basically PayPal has
thousands of developers and each of us
developers needs their space to go and
do creative things like creating their
VMs deploying their services running
applications or do things which is
something we want to provide the space
for them so when when you look at that
what they need is autonomy in doing that
which means that it is I would say that
DevOps is a very
a widely used term but it varies the
meaning of DevOps varies from company to
company person to person but what we
really think is that give the autonomy
to the developers so that they can do
what they need to do and and we don't
step into their sting at the same time
there were a lot of other things which
developers doesn't want to take care of
for example when we started at Google
Cloud
there was nothing called a sharp V PC so
the the model which existed was you
create a project and inside the project
there'll be a network which means that
every project has its own network which
means that every developer if I have to
give a project they we also have to
procreate a network inside the project
which means that we need to allocate an
IP range so we are talking about
hundreds of projects around even more
than that thousands of project and it's
a big nightmare for us to manage IP
ranges for each of these projects the
second thing is that the another main
principle we took up for public cloud is
everything should be automated which
means that when we set up something it's
not just the automation to create the
initial project but any maintenance
after that should be automated so if we
are creating a project for a developer
and if the network is within that so any
interconnectivity configuration or a
gateway configuration all exist within
the network so if you have to make a
change it's not making change in one
project we are talking about going and
making changes in thousands of projects
so it created a pretty difficult for us
to scale in that model and that's where
we work with Google and then we
partnered up and say that hey this is
are the problems and that's where we
started looking at Google introduced
this concept of shard VPC so I think
Neha and Iman will explain all the
topologies and everything so I'm not
putting any diagram here but I'm going
to explain what problems we faced when
we started initially and how we solved
in the shard VPC model so as I said in
the current industry there are two a
school of thoughts one is a complete
DevOps model where you give complete
control to the developer from start
and that means that you create an
account and give everything to developer
and developer managers from network to
compute to deploying applications and
everything and there's another extreme
thought which is basically completely
anti DevOps where everything is done by
somebody else and the developer gives a
code so what people what we did is that
we took a hybrid approach we really
figured out what each team should be
responsible for and where we should draw
the line and say that these are all your
developer responsibilities like compute
storage your code and everything you
manage it but anything below we want to
really standardize it and especially in
a big enterprise when you have thousands
of developers and thousands of projects
the standardization becomes very
critical in terms of security and also
auditing right if you want to change
something you need to know where to
change if it's in many places it becomes
very tricky so if you look at it as I
said IP management was one of the
problems right allocating IP ranges
assigning them and when the project is
deleted reassigning it somewhere it was
becoming a challenge which shot BBC the
model we adopted was that we have many
security zones in paper each security
zone is scarred out based on what data
can be stored what data can be accessed
what services can exist how the services
can interact
there's many criterias based on which we
card out zones for example there may be
a zone where the data resides which
means that nobody can enter into the
zone except through a single channel and
that would be protected but firewalls
data laws everything there so we have
this concept already built into our
private cloud we want to bring the
similar concept into public law that's
where this model of VPC became very
useful where we said that every VPC we
create is going to be a security zone
which means that within that security
zone it's open that if there are two VMs
they can communicate but any query to
come into that security room it has to
go through a firewall or it will have a
V PC peering with more security and
scrutinize ation there the second thing
is that as I said like once we have
shard V PC the management become more
simpler because we just need to manage
the connectivity at the shard V PC level
every service project which is created
doesn't need to worry about it so as far
as the developers are concerned they
just keep creating vm storage and
everything we started with a VPN based
approach and then now we are moving to
an direct interconnect so which means
that there's no impact of developers
because everything is centrally managed
at the Schad VPC level so this is a
functional representation of how we
divided the functionalities and felt
that this is the optimal way so that we
give enough freedom for developers to
play around with public cloud do things
what they need but at the same time we
don't need to overburden them with
responsibilities which they don't need
to take care of so if you look at it we
have a enterprise cloud team which is
comes with best practices of how many VP
C's has to be created how the VP C's has
to be interconnected like Pierre
appeared how they have to connect back
to the on-prem where should be the
routing configured all these are
centralized and automated through one
single mechanism so we manage everything
down and at the same time we have
automation to create projects which sets
a project up puts the right developers
there and give grants permission to this
network that's it once they get the
project within the project they have an
autonomy to do anything so in this
mechanism we were able to scale it to
thousands of projects and we are able to
manage it without any impact and the
future changes because we all know that
things a wall the cloud is going to a
wall that means we should also move
along with that so we built foundation
such a way that we can make more changes
in the future without with less impact
also another principle we took up is
there's another use case which is a test
zone which is basically running paper
comm inside paper which means that it is
a complete replication of PayPal inside
PayPal that means that we have to it is
use for our test environments the
integration testings and everything now
when we adopted a model which I showed
previously our goal is to see that the
same model can be applied for any use
cases which comes later like test
tomorrow it could be production or later
something else so in this case if you
look at the use case it's something's a
scale in terms of number of projects we
are talking about only a few tens of
projects but it's a huge resource
it's like thousands of VMs thousands of
gigabytes of storage and everything
because it's complete PayPal inside but
if you go into the model it's the same
we didn't change anything
we created a VP C which is already
automated which has all the features we
created the project in the same way we
just need to assign different teams to
these projects and within that they were
able to do everything they wanted so the
model is scalable to any use case which
we bring in and we are in the process of
next year trying to get public cloud
production use cases into public cloud
so we don't need to change much the same
automation which we created is going to
help us do this again said that as I
said it's a multi your journey we all
realize that this is something not
everything is available today and we
have to get this going so we have seen
that UPC has come in but again not every
services adopted VPC for example we
wanted to create database with the
private IP assigned from the V PC range
which would become available we will
start adopting it IP Elias is a great
feature which was released for us we
have a container networking technology
where we are saying IP to container so
for that IP Alice's is a great thing so
we are going to start using it and
similarly like as this technology was
our tools also install wall for example
we had evens which have been consumed
now since we have this host and a
service project isolation we need to
figure out how to collect even from
different service projects as from a
single place because we don't want to
deploy something on every service part
so we are also evolving as the
technology evolves and as Google is
maturing enough more with this we will
also be moving along with that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]